-Performing "Ceilings" from her
album "Five Seconds Flat,"
please welcome Lizzy McAlpine!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ceilings, plaster ♪
♪ Can't you just make it
move faster? ♪
♪ Lovely to be
sitting here with you ♪
♪ You're kinda cute,
but it's ♪
♪ Raining harder ♪
♪ My shoes are
now full of water ♪
♪ Lovely to be
rained on with you ♪
♪ It's kinda cute, but it's ♪
♪ So short ♪
♪ Then you're drivin' me home ♪
♪ And I don't wanna leave ♪
♪ But I have to go ♪
♪ You kiss me in your car ♪
♪ And it feels like the start of
a movie I've seen ♪
♪ Before ♪
♪ Bedsheets, no clothes ♪
♪ Touch me like
nobody else does ♪
♪ Lovely to just
lay here with you ♪
♪ You're kinda cute, and I ♪
♪ Would say all of this ♪
♪ But I don't wanna
ruin the moment ♪
♪ Lovely to sit between
comfort and chaos ♪
♪ But it's over ♪
♪ Then you're drivin' me home ♪
♪ And it kinda comes out ♪
♪ As I get up to go ♪
♪ You kiss me in your car ♪
♪ And it feels like the start of
a movie I've seen before ♪
♪ But it's not real ♪
♪ And you don't exist ♪
♪ And I can't recall
the last time I was kissed ♪
♪ It hits me in the car ♪
♪ And it feels like
the end of a movie I've seen ♪
♪ Before ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!